we're in a supermarket in Harlem
Netherland this was a cracking idea
we're home experimenter all when wills
is pitching the plan astonishing thing
about this clip is not that a quail
hatched out of an egg it's that a quail
hatched out of a supermarket egg that
does not usually happen meet Albert the
homegrown quail chick
i won but if supermarket eggs don't
normally hatch how did albert beat the
odds when i wind up the eggs home he put
them in an incubator 37 degrees celsius
or 99 degrees fahrenheit the temperature
is important too high or too low and the
embryo inside the egg will develop
abnormally it's also important to turn
the eggs over regularly to keep the
embryo from sticking to the shell so
Alwyn did this with his twelve eggs and
nineteen days later one of them hatched
and out came a Japanese quail named
Albert but why did only one egg hatch
fern egg to hatch a rooster has to mate
with a hen prior to the egg being laid
so the egg can be fertilized now in most
commercial egg-laying operations they
keep the hens and roosters completely
separate to avoid fertilization there
are a couple of possible explanations
for why Albert was able to defy the odds
first a rogue male could have either
been misidentified or perhaps snuck in
to where some females were additionally
some free-range farms may keep one or
two males and it's found that this
changes social structure reduces
aggression and actually keeps the
females feeling safe so inevitably some
of them will be carrying fertilized eggs
your supermarket eggs are not gonna
hatch on their own and they are
perfectly safe to eat and here's Albert
now all grown up and having a quail of a
time